years of effort to create an environment
in which the kinds of creative teaching
the Tracy represents is allowed to
flourish we thank you for this
recognition in closing I would like to
also welcome the education leaders from
Florida who are here and those
representing the national education
groups who have also come I'd like to
recognize that Tracy's congressman
representative Jim Backus in the back
himself a great advocate of Education
and I'd like to remind all of you that
the ultimate purpose of the National
Teacher of the Year award is to find a
way for the rest of us to express our
appreciation to people all across this
country who give their lives to our
children all the teachers of this
country who get up every day and do
their best to try to advance the cause
of learning for all the children of
America they are in so many ways our
most important public servants thank you
very much
[Applause]
[Music]
I have a statement I would like to read
now when the sirens go down on the
events in Waco yesterday and then I will
be happy to answer the questions that
you have
they all get a suntan before this
happened it's like Florida isn't it we
tried to make you feel right at home
they're going in a circle instead of on
February the 28th for federal agents
were killed in the line of duty trying
to enforce the law against the Branch
Davidian compound which had illegally
stockpiled weaponry and ammunition and
placed innocent children at risk because
the B ATF operation had failed to meet
its objective a 51-day standoff ensued
the Federal Bureau of Investigation then
made every reasonable effort to bring
this perilous situation to an end
without bloodshed and further loss of
life
the bureau's efforts were ultimately
unavailing because the individual with
whom they were dealing David Koresh was
dangerous irrational and probably insane
he engaged in numerous activities which
violated both federal law and common
standards of decency he was moreover
responsible for the deaths and injuries
which occurred during the action against
the compound in February given his
inclination toward violence and in an
effort to protect his young hostages no
provocative actions were taken from more
than seven weeks by federal agents
against the compound this weekend I was
briefed by Attorney General Reno on an
operation prepared by the FBI designed
to increase pressure on korish and
persuade those in the compound to
surrender peacefully the plan included a
decision to withhold the use of
ammunition even in the face of fire and
instead to use tear gas that would not
cause permanent harm to health but wood
it was hoped force the people in the
compound to come outside and to
surrender I was informed of the plan to
end the siege I discuss it with Attorney
General Reno I ask the questions I
thought it was a
opiate for me to ask I then told her to
do what she thought was right and I take
full responsibility for the
implementation of the decision
yesterday's action ended in a horrible
human tragedy mr. choruses response to
the demands for his surrender by federal
agents was to destroy himself and murder
the children who were his captors as
well as all the other people who were
there who did not survive he killed
those he controlled and he bears
ultimate responsibility for the carnage
that ensued
now we must review the past with an eye
toward the future I have directed the
United States departments of justice and
Treasury to undertake a vigorous and
thorough investigation to uncover what
happened and why and whether anything
could have been done differently I have
told the department's to involve
independent professional law enforcement
officials in the investigation
I expect to receive analysis and answers
and whatever time is required to
complete the review finally I have
directed the departments to cooperate
fully with all congressional enquiries
so that we can continue to be fully
accountable to the American people I
want to express my appreciation to the
Attorney General to the Justice
Department and to the federal agents on
the front lines who did the best job
they could under deeply difficult
circumstances again I want to say as I
did on yesterday I'm very sorry for the
loss of life which occurred at the
beginning and at the end of this tragedy
in Waco I hope very much that others who
will be tempted to join cults and to
come involved with people like David
Koresh will be deterred by the horrible
scenes they have seen over the last
seven weeks and I hope very much that
the difficult situations which federal
agents have confronted there in which
they will be doubtless required to
confront in other contexts and the
futures will be somewhat better handled
and better understood because of what
has been learned now
you know outlined to you and 15
conversation you had with her on Sunday
could you describe what she told you on
Sunday about the nature of the operation
and how you knew about it I was I was
told by the Attorney General that the
FBI strongly felt that the time had come
to take another step in trying to
dislodge the people in the compound and
she described generally what the
operation would be that they wanted to
go in and use tear gas which had been
tested not to cause permanent damage to
adults or the children but which would
make it very difficult for people to
stay inside the building and it was
hoped that the tear gas would permit
them to come outside I was further told
that under no circumstances would our
people fire any shots at them even if
fired upon they were going to shoot the
tear gas from armored vehicles which
would protect them and there would be no
exchange of fire in fact as you know an
awful lot of shots were fired by the
cult members at the federal officials
there were no shots coming back from the
government side I asked a number of
questions the first question I asked is
why now we have waited 7 weeks why now
the reasons I was given were the
following number one that there was a
limit to how long the federal
authorities could maintain with their
limited resources the quality and
intensity of coverage by experts there
they might be needed in other parts of
the country number two that the people
who had reviewed this had never seen a
case quite like this one before and they
were convinced that no progress had been
made recently and no progress was going
to be made through the normal means of
getting korish and the other cult
members to come out number three that
the danger of they're doing something to
themselves or to others was likely to
increase not be
with the passage of time and number four
that they had reason to believe that the
children who were still inside the
compound were being abused significantly
as well as being forced to live in
unsanitary and unsafe conditions so for
those reasons they wanted to move at
that time the second question I asked
the Attorney General is whether they had
given consideration to all the the
things that could go wrong and evaluated
them against what might happen that was
good she said that the FBI personnel on
the scene and those working with them
were convinced that the chances of bad
things happening would only increase
with the passage of time the third
question I asked was has the military
been consulted as soon as the initial
tragedy came to light in Waco that's the
first thing I asked to be done because
it was obvious that this was not a
typical law enforcement situation
military people were then brought in
helped to analyze the situation and some
of the problems that were presented by
and so I asked if the military had been
consulted the Attorney General said that
they had and that they were in basic
agreement that there was only one minor
tactical difference of opinion between
the FBI and the military something that
both sides thought was not of
overwhelming significance having asked
those questions and gotten those answers
I said that she thought it was the right
thing to do that she should proceed and
that I would support it and I stand by
that today now go ahead that's the
widespread perception reported widely
television radio and newspapers that you
were trying somehow to distance herself
from those I made no public statement
yesterday let me say the only reason I
made no public statement yesterday is
that I had nothing to add than what was
being said and I literally did not know
until rather late in the day whether
anybody was still alive other than those
who had been actually seen and taken to
the hospital or taken into custody I it
was purely and simply a question of
waiting for events to unfold they
was that I have you know I can't account
for why people speculated one way or the
other but I I talked to the Attorney
General on the day before the action
took place I talked to her yesterday I
called her again late last night after
she appeared on the Larry King show and
I talked to her again this morning
president is not it's not possible for a
president to distance himself from
things that happen when the federal
government is in control I will say this
however I was frankly surprised would be
a mild word to say that anyone that
would suggest that the Attorney General
should resign because some religious
fanatics murdered themselves and I I
regret what happened but it is not
possible in this life to control the
behavior of others in every circumstance
these people killed for federal
officials in the line of duty
they were heavily armed they fired on
federal officials yesterday repeatedly
and they were never fired back on we did
everything we could to avoid the loss of
life they made the decision to immolate
themselves and I regret it terribly and
I feel awful about the children but in
the end the last comment I had from
Janet Reno is when I talked to her on
Sunday I said now I want you to tell me
once more why you believe not why they
believe why you believe we should move
now rather than wait some more and she
said it's because of the children they
have evidence that those children are
still being abused and that they're in
increasingly unsafe conditions and that
they don't think it will get any easier
with time with the passage of time I
have to take their word for that so that
is where I think things stand Helen view
of the outcome that you didn't run out
of patience and if you had it to do over
again would you really decide that way
no well I I think what you can assume is
just exactly what I announced today
this is a the FBI has done a lot of
things right for this country over a
long period of time you know this is the
same FBI that found the people that
bombed the World Trade Center in
lickety-split record time I we want an
inquiry to analyze the steps along the
way
is there something else we should have
known is there some other question they
should have asked is there some other
question I should have asked can I say
for sure that no one that we could have
done nothing else to make the outcome
come different I don't know that that's
why I want the inquiry and that's why I
would like to to make sure we have some
independent law enforcement people not
political people but totally
non-political outside experts who can
bring to Garrett Baer the best evidence
we have there is a unfortunately a rise
in this sort of fanaticism all across
the world and we may have to confront it
again and I want to know whether there
is anything else that we can do
particularly when there are children
involved but I do think it is important
to recognize that that the wrongdoers in
this case were the people who killed
others and then killed themselves yes
presented to you for resolving this
situation at any point from February
28th until yesterday oh well yes I got
regular reports all along the way there
there were lots of other options pursued
if you go back at you all covered it
very well the FBI
you did a very good job of it I mean you
the FBI and the other authorities there
pursued any number of other options all
along the way and a lot of them early on
seem to be working some of the children
got out some of the other people left
there was a there was a at one point
there seemed to be some lines of
communication opening up between Korres
and the authorities and then he would
say things and not do them and things
just began to spend downward whether
there were other on yesterday in terms
of what happened yesterday the decision
the conversation I had with the Attorney
General did not involve other options
except whether we should take more time
the present strategy we were pursuing
because they said they wanted to do this
because they thought this was the best
way to get people out of the compound as
quickly before they could kill
themselves that's what they thought
congressional hearing one situation
concert are you an agreement of that
well that's up to the Congress they can
do whatever they want but I think it's
very important that the Treasury and
Justice Department's launched this
investigation and bring in some outside
export experts and as I said in my
statement if any congressional
committees want to look into that we
will fully cooperate there's nothing to
hide here oh this was probably the most
well covered operation of its kind in
the history of the country did so the
children had no chance because this gas
was very she said he was not lethal but
it was very dangerous to the children
they could not have survived without gas
masks and on February the 28th let's go
back didn't those people have a right to
practice our religion they were not just
practicing their religion they were the
the the Treasury Department that
believed that they had violated federal
laws any number of them now and let me
go back and answer I can't answer the
question about the gas mask except to
tell you that that the whole purpose of
using the tear gas was it had been
tested they were convinced that it
wouldn't kill either a child or an adult
but it would force anybody who breathed
it to run outside and one of the things
that I've heard I don't want to get into
the details of this because I don't know
but one of the things that they were
speculating about today was that the
wind was blowing so fast that the wind
the windows might have been opened in
some of the gas might have escaped and
that may be why it didn't have the
desired effect they also knew Sarah that
the that there was an underground
compound of a bus buried underground
where the children could be sent and and
and there were I think they were hoping
very much that the children were not
really
immediately outside that the humane
thing would be done and that the
children would be sent someplace where
they could be protected in terms of the
gas masks themselves I learned yesterday
I did not ask this fact question before
that the gas was supposed to stay active
in the compound longer than the gas
masks themselves were to work so that it
was thought that even if they all had
gas masks that eventually the gas would
force them out in a non violent non
shooting circumstance Janet Reno about
the possibility of a mass suicide and
when you learned about the actual fire
and the explosion what went through your
mind during those horrendous moments
what I asked Janet Reno is if they
considered all the worst things that
could happen and she said and of course
the whole issue of suicide had been
raised in the public you know they he
had that had been debated anyway and she
said that the people who were most
knowledgeable about these kinds of
issues concluded that there was no
greater risk of that now than there
would be tomorrow or the next day or the
day after that or at any time in the
future that was the judgment they made
whether they were right or wrong of
course we will never know what happened
you know when I saw the fire when I saw
the building burning I was sick I felt
terrible and I would my immediate
concern was whether the children had
gotten out and whether they were
escaping or whether they had were inside
trying to burn themselves up that's why
the first thing I wanted to know Thank
You Janet Reno's decision isn't it in
the end your decision well what I'm
saying is that I didn't have a four or
five-hour detailed briefing from the FBI
I didn't go over every strategic part of
it it is a decision for which I take
responsibility I'm the president United
States and I signed off on
general decision and giving her the
authority to make the last call when I
talked to her on Sunday sometime had a
laugh she might have made a decision too
to change her mind I said if you decide
to go forward with this tomorrow I will
support you and I do support her it is
not he is not ultimately responsible to
the American people I am but I think she
has conducted her duties and in a